[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 minutes les invités ravis
de vous retrouver voici le sommaire de
ce jeudi 6 juillet 2010 est une rentrée
scolaire se prépare un an à l'avancé
celle de 2017 portera certainement déjà
la marque du nouveau président emmanuel
macron en effet plusieurs de ses
promesses devraient se concrétiser
rapidement comme ramené à 12 le nombre
d'élèves des classes de cp et ce1 dans
les réseaux prioritaire mais aussi la
réforme des rythmes scolaires c'est du
collège du baccalauréat nous en
parlerons avec notre invité bertrand
mesure du syndicat snuipp fsu
l'établissement français du sang même qu
une campagne se délient julien pour
sensibiliser à donner son sang car la
durée de vie des produits sanguins est
limité cinq jours pour les plaquettes 42
pour les globules rouges
les dons de sang doit être régulier et
constant même en été au total dix mille
dons par jour sont nécessaires pour
faire face aux besoins en france ils
recevront tout à l'heure suzanne van est
la responsable des prélèvements sur
l'ouest hippie noie met tout de suite
bonsoir éducation réforme des rythmes
scolaires division par deux des
effectifs dans les classes de cp et de
ce1 qui se trouvent dans des secteurs
défavorisés mais aussi réforme du
baccalauréat ou réforme du collège pour
en parler nous recevons aujourd'hui
bertrand mesure vous êtes du syndicat
snuipp fsu bon soir bonsoir
alors donc sur le papier la promesse
était séduisante un candidat s'était
engagé le président macron à réduire à
12 le nombre d'élèves dans les classes
de cp et de ce1 en d'éducation pardon
prioritaire au nom de la lutte contre
l'échec scolaire et les inégalités
mais la mise en oeuvre de la réforme se
se révèle pardon être un petit peu un
casse-tête en certains endroits des
difficultés se posent concernant les
salles concernant les enseignants est ce
que vous vous pouvez un petit peu nous
parler de cette mise en place qui
pourrait être possible à la rentrée à
écouter je crois que la première marque
affaire c'est que c'est une bonne chose
que enfin le ministère prenne en compte
un fait qui établit quand même depuis
très longtemps à savoir que le nombre
d'élèves par classe est un facteur de
réussite pour tous les élèves et en
particulier pour son action éducation
prioritaire
maintenant reste à voir les conditions
dans lesquelles cette prise en compte ce
fait et qui du point de vue des
enseignants des parents et puis même du
système en général se fait dans une dans
un chaos assez quand même caractérisée
vous avez évoqué les salles mais on peut
aussi évoquer les personnels le concours
de professeur des écoles a de plus en
plus de mal à recruter pour la deuxième
année le concours de l'académie de
versailles est déficitaire c'est à dire
que il ya moins de recruter que de
postes offerts aux concours
donc va se poser un problème qui est un
problème à la fois de ressources
humaines
il manquera les personnels et puis en
même temps après même de ressources
budgétaires puisque vous avez entendu le
premier ministre
le budget de l'éducation nationale ne va
pas être sanctuarisé donc cette
ouverture sur une diminution des
effectifs en classe de cp
cette année puis de c1 en éducation
prioritaire se fera par redéploiement
c'est à dire qu'on va enlever aux seins
ce que l'on va donner aux autres et ça a
déjà commencé pour la prochaine rentrée
puisque y compris en éducation
prioritaire
il y a des
des niveaux de classe il par exemple la
maternelle qui va perdre des moyens
supplémentaires qui m'était accordé
jusqu'à présent pour permettre
l'ouverture de ces deux ccpa 12 camps
j'ajouterai que pour les communes c'est
un vrai casse tête
la décision était prise très récemment
les communes ne sont pas en capacité de
se retourner aussi rapidement et si ce
qui est prévu se met effectivement en
place c'est-à-dire la montée cp et ce1
sur l'ensemble de l'éducation
prioritaire
les communes n'auront pas les moyens de
faire face en termes de salles de classe
c'est évident alors à ce propos on
concernant l'autre le nombre
d'enseignants supplémentaires qui
seraient nécessaires un petit peu le
gouvernement a parlé de 12000 il va ont
prélevé en partie sur les enseignants
qui s'occupait de plus de mettre que de
placer sa voix là et est-ce qu'il y aura
est ce qu'on vous a fait des promesses
concernant des embauches à écouter les
promesses concernant les embauches je
crois que elle se heurte à la volonté
budgétaire du gouvernement
d'autre part c'est ce que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure les plus de maîtres queux
casse vont être déployés à terme on sait
qu'il risque de se passer ce qui s'est
passé en 2008 c'est à dire que étant
donné qu'il n'y aura pas plus de moyens
budgétaires et que la ressource humaine
de toute façon ne sera pas là on risque
de se retrouver dans des situations on
va prendre sur la brigade de
remplacement sur les réseaux dead etc et
déjà cette idée de dispatcher un petit
peu les enseignants bas il ya surtout
cette idée de redéployer les moyens qui
avait été un petit peu améliorées ces
dernières années et de les recentrer sur
ce dispositif
j'ajouterai que la préoccupation qui est
de
dès les élèves en éducation prioritaire
ne doit pas faire oublier que les
moyenne par classe de l'école primaire
française sont extrêmement élevés et et
ne correspondent absolument pas à la
moyenne par exemple des pays comparables
de le céder j'ajouterai un dernier point
c'est que notre ministre a évalué le
sous-investissement dans l'école
primaire à 30% par rapport à la moyenne
des pays de l'osce et de comparable donc
voilà on est devant une vraie difficulté
qui est une difficulté budgétaire et une
difficulté en ressources humaines et la
précipitation n'est pas une bonne chose
il faut que les choses se pose dans la
continuité dans la durée à cela va
s'ajouter évidemment puisque vous savez
qu'on est dans une période budgétaire à
ses contraintes des méthodes
d'évaluation extrêmement agressive dont
on le sait que par exemple aux états
unis et aux autres en angleterre elles
n'ont absolument pas produit permis de
vraiment piloter le système est de
savoir ce qui se passait dans les
classes alors outre sujet parce qu'on le
temps nous pressent la semaine de quatre
jours
quel est votre sentiment quelle est
votre position sur ce retour proposée
aux villes par un décret qui a été donc
qui est paru la semaine dernière
proposait aux villes de revenir à cette
semaine des quatre jours alors écoutez
si j'en crois les derniers éléments qui
ont été données au comité départemental
d'éducation nationale c'est à peu près
actuellement sur les yvelines la moitié
des communes ce qui représente à peu
près la moitié des élèves qui seraient
susceptibles de repasser à quatre jours
soit cette rentrée-là soit en 2018 et
pour un décret qui est paru le 28 juin
le constat qu'on avait faits et qui
était toujours et qui est toujours
d'actualité c'est que cette réforme
c'est mal mise en place qu'elle n'a pas
été fondamentalement concertée et
réfléchie et que de toute façon les
réserves que nous avions à l'époque sur
les inégalités territoriales etc
ces réserves là n'ont absolument pas été
levée par le gouvernement précédent
le retour à quatre jours est une volonté
très partagés des parents des
enseignants et des communes puisque ça
permet de faire des économies
budgétaires
donc le constat qui va certainement se
faire d'ici un à deux ans et que les
personnes qui vont rester les communes
qui vont rester à quatre jours et demi
seront très minoritaire merci le temps
nous presse malheureusement beaucoup
d'autres sujets nous y reviendrons une
prochaine fois
l'établissement français du sang même
donc une campagne ce début juillet pour
sensibiliser à donner son sang les
besoins étant toujours important nicolas
landry a reçu docteur susan va n'est
responsable des prélèvements
l'ile-de-france et ouest à le f s ils
étaient plus de 5,5 millions de donneurs
en 2016 près de 3 millions de
prélèvements ont été réalisés mais les
besoins sont toujours insuffisants
concernant le don du sang
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
suzanne van et bonjour bonjour alors
suzanne gaz et jaur alors je rappelle
que vous êtes responsable des
prélèvements ile de france ouest à
l'établissement français du sang alors
la situation est-elle alarmant
actuellement au premier semestre 2010
est alors c'est pas tout à fait au
premier semestre 2010 cette mélasse et
avant les vacances avant l'été comme
très souvent malheureusement et bien les
donneurs partent en vacances
heureusement ils vont se reposer mais il
oublie de temps en temps de pouvoir
donner aussi et alors que les malades
eux sont toujours là sur les lieux de
vacances ils ne peuvent pas avoir des
accès pour donner leur sang
bien sûr ils peuvent y aller il ya
beaucoup d'endroits partout en france on
peut donner
et d'ailleurs je les invite à la
regarder sur notre site
f s
don de sang dont 200 points pourrait
n'être cela s'affichera tout à l'heure
et
sur ce site ils peuvent effectivement
voir les endroits où on va donner
donc ils peuvent aussi prendre un peu de
temps sur leurs vacances pour aller
donner en vacances quels sont les
besoins nécessaires pour l'été alors
l'été et tous les jours de l'année en
fait nous avons besoin pour
pouvoir traiter les malades avec les
avec des transfusions de dix mille dons
par jour mais tous les jours
donc c'est tous les jours donc les
personnes qui viennent une fois dans
l'année
s'il pouvait venir une deuxième fois ça
permettrait de deux probablement ne pas
avoir à faire des appels aux dons
dix mille dons par jour à quoi sert
c'est à quoi sert cette dix mille dons
par jour alors plusieurs maladies
peuvent être traités par le parent par
la transfusion
on pense souvent aux patients qui sont
traitées pour un cancer et le traitement
du cancer tue aussi les cellules du sang
et c'est pour ça qu'on fait des
transfusions pour pouvoir aussi faire
récupérer ces personnes qui sont traités
par le camp pour le cancer
il ya d'autres maladies il ya des
personnes qui par exemple on pense aux
hémophiles qui n'ont pas ces deux
facteurs de coagulation et qu'on peut
leur donner par là on pense aussi à la
drépanocytose
il ya beaucoup d'autres maladies a
beaucoup de maladies qu'on peut traiter
par le sang est un produit naturel et
qu'on ne peut pas faire en laboratoire
combien de personnes sont sauvés par an
grâce au don du sang est bien un million
de personnes sont transfusées chaque
année et pour ça il faut effectivement
environ 4 millions de donneurs
régulièrement chaque année pour sauver
ce million de personnes alors vous
l'avez dit on est en été les vacances
commencent les donneurs sont peut-être
sur leur lieu de vacances déjà mais y at
il des
soin particulier sur cette certaine
période alors il ya les besoins
particuliers c'est simplement
effectivement que les stocks
avec la chaleur les gens ne sont pas
venus donner on peut le comprendre
cependant effectivement du coup les
stocks on aime bien avoir cent dix mille
sont actuellement autour de 80 82 milles
donc vous voyez ça fait 1-1 quart
un cinquième qui n'est pas encore là et
donc ça peut être inquiétant parce que
dans tous ses stocks bien sûr il ya la
variété de tous les groupes sanguins et
dès que le stock diminue et la variété
diminue aussi forcément vous parlez des
groupes sanguins différents groupes pour
les rappels a + b + au plus quels sont
les besoins sur quel groupe
y at il vraiment de réels besoins tous
les groupes sont intéressantes parce que
en fait c'est essentiellement la variété
donc plus on va voir de donneurs plus on
va avoir
ça va être représentatif de la
population des malades aussi parce que
ça se superposent et plus on va avoir
deux donneurs plus on va pouvoir pour un
malade particulier qui va avoir un
groupe plus spécifiques être sûr d'avoir
en réserve ce groupe à lui donner et
donc de faire une transfusion de qualité
peut-on rappeler les conditions à
remplir pour donner son sang alors il
faut être
c'est presque comme la chance y ans et
de 18 ans à 78 en 70 ans la veille des
71 ans pour être exact et puis il faut
ne pas avoir ne pas avoir de problèmes
de coeur pulmonaire ne pas avoir de
cancer pour les grandes les grandes les
grandes maladies il faut éviter
évidemment on va pas prendre du sens
chez quelqu'un qui est déjà malade et
puis il ya certaines circonstances quand
on va dans certains pays
eh bien les les mouches les différentes
insectes peuvent transmettre des
maladies et à ce moment là il va falloir
si on revient dans ces pays
attendre un petit peu avant de donner
merci suzanne van est et si vous
souhaitez donner votre sang trouver un
lieu pour donner votre sang vous pouvez
retrouver ces informations sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
suzanne van et merci encore pour cette
interview merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la fin de ce set 8 les invités
merci de votre fidélité airplay sur
notre site internet tv fil 78 points
comme et sur notre application
à bientôt
[Musique]